Ma che è sto schifo Ma perché devi fare
così ma non puoi devo fare il cambio di
stagione so il cambio di stagione ce
l'ha hanno i miei a Torino quindi io qua
avevo solo questa maglia di lana Cioè
non ce n'altra e devo portare tutta la
roba estiva a Torino dobbiamo prendere
un po' di roba a prendere la roba e
portarla a Torino nel mentre Siccome il
garage è gremito di ricordi di quando
ero piccolo Oggi scopriremo Che minchia
c'è nel mio garage Allora
questo questo e poi ci sono tutte le
buste in entrata sono tutte pieghe non
sapevo dove mette la roba da portare
quindi l'ho messa negli zaini Mmm non
l'avevo capito
gli ha dato non mi servi per fare questo
video se non per portare la roba vabbè
musica di undertail Dog qualcosa
Eccoci qua
signori un cane tranquillo
ho un Deja Vu L'ho già visto sta scena
io sono Favij e questa è la mia nuova e
l'abbiamo già fatta sta roba Ragazzi
allora siccome dal video in cui abbiamo
aperto quell'affare
tutti quanti avete chiesto che cosa
tengo qua dentro di De Lorenzo piccolo è
partito tutto dal dal triciclo perché io
ho fatto vedere sto triciclo qua nel
video sempre con Diletta farei una
Reaction delle cose del Lorenzo piccolo
che è ormai è sepolto qua dentro che ha
detto così insomma un po' fortissimo
brutto brutto GS mappanese questa
squadra ma ci sono i parastinchi dentro
ma stiamo scherzando Infatti manca le
scarpe ma tutto attorno a tutto qua è
rimasto Ma che le linee uh uh queste
scarpe hanno segnato un sacco ma proprio
un sacco di Golfo frate nella porta Però
una volta ci siamo scontrati eh contro
la Juve i pulcini della Juventus Quindi
quelli della mia età Grazie 95 eravamo
bambini però della Juve sai quanto
abbiamo perso No papà quanto abbiamo
perso Gira su papà che è orgoglioso di
me 13 a 0 mi pare
l'uno e l'uno 31-0 Infatti poi ho
cambiato squadra e mi sa di fare il
Barcellona c'è una cosa nelle scuole
italiane che io non ho mai capito ma che
cazzo serve però ce l'hanno tutti frate'
i regoli Ma dove sei andato a scuola i
regoli i regoli servivano erano pezzi di
plastica e che cazzo servivano raga
tutti ce l'avevano tranne lui ce
l'avevano dai ragazzi Tra l'altro Ah
bellissimo studiare tu potevi cambiare
quello che c'era sulla lavagna Fammi
vedere ci tengo alla bellaccia io Capito
c'erano dei cerchietti e tu dovevi
disegnare il volto dei personaggi della
tua classe cioè delle persone che stanno
nella tua classe il primo
una nota bro tu la nota Sì bro una nota
Lorenzo è ancora insicuro sulle regole
delle aree della circonferenza del
cerchio e mi raccomando firma
Comunque vabbè e attenzione prima della
Rowling gli animali fantastici cosa non
ricordo questo schiacciavi su queste
questi facevano un rumore che sono
passati 25 anni quindi penso non
funzioni più
e a quanto pare non è così Ma come fa a
funzionare dopo 62 anni sta a fare
Ecco che magari lo usiamo nei video
sembra vero
manganello Perché mio papà mi insegnava
a fare le rapine tu sai che per iniziare
a fare lo youtuber All'inizio io non
avevo tutto programma materiale questo è
stato il primo computer con cui ho
montato il primo video
Ecco qua Happy Wheels Ma signori perché
iniziare a istruirsi sin da piccoli
sulla patente a punti non ci credo non è
comunque servito una sega sta roba a
quanto pare Oh questo si chiamava robo
Raptor robo Raptor era un robot che tu
schiacciavi in tasca e andava in giro e
faceva casino per casa Praticamente è
Sum solo che non gli dovevi dare da
mangiare bellissimo Guarda eh sono un
pacco di una fan
eh alta moda questa no questa era il mio
era Dragons posso farlo
Ragazzi abbiamo 25 anni aspetta qua Lo
voglio vedere ragazzi
[Musica]
sono visti i pantaloni strappati con il
bottone che è partito bene è partito un
bottone nei pantaloni ragazzi perfetto
sta ingrassando No è che ho fatto lo
sforzo Allora qua c'è roba talmente
vecchia che forse alcune cose non me le
ricordo vero Cosplay
Ecco qua
è un pugno
poi c'è la corazza Eccola qua Eccoci
Signori si va a Lucca Comics Questa è
stata la mia sedia da Gaming fino ai
12-13 anni mi sa ma quanto è piccola
però io questa sedia giocava la
Playstation sostituto su questa sedia e
poi c'è anche l'altro cioè questa è
l'upgrade perché c'era anche quella
prima eh Cioè adesso vi faccio vedere la
mia postazione da Gaming era questa qua
incredibile
fate fare dei crack strani questa era la
mia postazione da Gaming ragazzi cioè io
stavo su questa sedia e questo era il
banco qui la mia scrivania e sopra
C'avevo La il televisore bruttissimo
piccolo quadrato con la Playstation 1 2
e giocavo così da per dieci anni Sono
davanti così sono molto emozionato Si
vede anche il mio
ombrellone non mi hanno fatto mai
mancare nulla
i miei sarebbe il rimborso ancora faccio
una storia faccio una storia e scrivo Ah
È maschio gifted c'è un'ultima roba che
vorrei fare però devo dare fondo a tutto
il mio coraggio ma lo farò lo faccio
questa roba non scende dalla sopra da
almeno 20 anni Immagino questa è la
prima volta che tocca terra questa terra
non è uscito da qua negli ultimi 20 anni
Ecco qua hai visto com'è cambiato il
mondo
[Musica]
Guarda che si rompe Ciao ragazzi stato
Arrivederci
No loro non hai idee che cos'hai No non
hai idea Non hai idea di quello che hai
qua No vabbè no lo può buttare quindi
ragazzi Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto
e quindi si ritorna Ma cosa scegli
ok